hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
we may all be locked up indoors for the
next six months but thankfully it's
happening at just the right time for
video game releases April is the first
huge month when you games and if you're
counting your pennies I found a free to
play game to here's 10 games coming
throughout April 2020 like I was going
to start anywhere else resident evil 3
nemesis the survival horror masterpiece
has been dragged kicking and screaming
from 1999 to present day retelling the
story of Jill Valentine and her
miraculous escape from Raccoon City mid
zombie outbreak the real showstopper
here is the nemesis a seemingly
unkillable juggernaut hell-bent on
hunting down stars team members and Jill
is a top of that hit list the way the
game is designed will give you repeated
heart attacks the Nemesis can appear at
any time and physically blocked Jill's
path unlike the tyrant in LA she is re
to remake the nemesis can run it's
absolutely petrifying on top of this
included in the game is re resistance an
asymmetric multiplayer game where a
group of survivors must attempt to
escape an evil mastermind who will try
to bring them down constantly this adds
another option and adds replayability to
a game focused on single-player horror
storytelling your kinda game let us know
in the comments and if you're looking
for someone to play with I am to throw
your psn in the comments below
resident evil 3 nemesis releases on
April 3rd on ps4 PC and Xbox
[Music]
only seven days after re3 comes another
1990s remake this time Final Fantasy 7
remake playing as Cloud Strife with his
iconic Buster Sword we will begin a
journey to take down the corrupt Shinra
mega corporation the real change from
1997 is the updated combat mechanics
which now include hack and slash wailing
away but the real finesse is layering
the attack combination the magic
resources together to win battles with
tactical knowledge for example certain
attacks work better on machine based
foes that kind of thing
this can be hugely overwhelming but
check out another key mechanic slowing
down time to take a moment out of the
fight and plan your next move it's hard
to explain how something so hectic can
have so much downtime if needed a
sticking point for many people is the
end point of the game which is around
fifth of the full game back in 1997 but
don't be put off by this this game won't
be sure to due to that it's a
full-length game which breaks down the
mid gas section of the original outing
and develops that into a full-length
game I hope that makes sense there's
more content break this doesn't span
thus far I'm not explaining this very
well am i anyway if you didn't know
already there's a demo out now it's
really good I recommend it and you'll
know right away if this game is for you
Final Fantasy 7 remake is a one-year ps4
exclusive releasing on April 10th
[Music]
so I found the new free-to-play game
this month and it's another battle
royale title I wasn't sure whether to
include it as warzone he's likely taking
over your life right now anyway here it
is this is dogfighter World War 2 a
battle royale game in the skies as you
pilot World War 2 planes it's the usual
battle royale scenario in solo play
anyway where everyone takes on everyone
else in the hopes of being the last bird
in the sky 40 players go head to head to
head to head to head to head you get the
idea if this is your kind of thing it's
out right now but there is one caveat
it's not out just yet in Europe most
likely because of languages we have
quite a few languages over here so it
takes time for things to be ready but if
you're in North America or Asia
it's all yours on ps4 right now I'm in
the EU I haven't tried it yet so if you
try it please give us a review below is
it worth playing or is it just another
battle royale cash in next up is a DLC
for everyone's favorite game in the
whole wide world
fallout 76 ok before you skip this I
know fallout 76 was a dumpster fire on
release but I also know the amount of
work that has gone into bringing this
dead cat back to life fallout 76 is
wastelanders expansion finally adds NPCs
to the world permanently not as a test
that has a core mechanic to the game and
thankfully it's a free expansion which
in my eyes has the potential to see the
glory days of Fallout return maybe I
shouldn't get my hopes up but I am very
tempted to try this the release date was
April 7th but due to the virus we can't
talk about on YouTube it's been moved
back seven days to April 14th are you
going to try it do you already play it
I'd love to know your thoughts
[Music]
let's look at a few physics-based games
designed for sandbox shenanigans have
you heard of totally reliable delivery
service it's been around on PC for a
while now but on April 1st sees the
game's full release across many
platforms you end up to three others
such spawning total are tasked with
delivering parcels around this open
world and well see for yourself
everything can be used to get you there
the game doesn't take itself too
seriously and could be a perfect game to
get people together over the Internet
now most of us are stuck indoors totally
reliable delivery service releases on
ps4 Xbox PC switch and even mobile on
April 1st and don't worry about cost it
isn't a full price game on the flip side
of that is another physics based game
which looks similar at first glance but
it is quite different this is moving out
in this we play our certified furniture
relocation technicians yeah in laymen
terms with just the removal guy your
task is to race to do your job as
quickly as possible without smashing and
breaking everything in your path as this
is a multiplayer game this quickly
becomes a mess for a good mess you know
what I mean made by the same people who
brought us over cooked moving out is in
the same vein of madness shouting at
everyone you play with and coordinating
towards victory and the perfect removal
job if moving out is your jam pick it up
on April 28th on ps4 switch Xbox and PC
[Music]
next let's go back to the 1980s and the
iconic Arnold Schwarzenegger movie
predator now it's a multiplayer video
game made by the same people who brought
us Friday the 13th a few years back this
is another asymmetric multiplayer game
one person plays as the predator and
attempt to wipe out a team of four
mercenaries those mercs are also played
by other real people who are on their
own mission when the predator attacks on
top of that our AI controlled factions
who will attempt to kill both the
predator and the mercenaries it's gonna
be damn hectic the predator plays in
third-person while the mercs are in
first-person a very interesting attempt
to update the evolve formats have you
ever played that one does it interest
you enough to buy it though the game is
coming to ps4 and PC on April 24 just in
case you think I'm ignoring Xbox players
here's one for you Gears tactics have
you ever played XCOM man that was a
great game while combine that with Gears
law and you know what to expect here
turn-based tactical movement kind of
like a chessboard but all the pieces
have hardware Iron Man would be proud of
April 28th if that's your thing
[Music]
here's something I don't expect to
release in April but that's their
deadline so let's cover it all the same
this is a new Minecraft game this is
minecraft dungeons but it isn't survival
like you'd know this version is a
dungeon crawler filled with mobs to
dispatch the game will support foreplay
a local and online cooperative plate
with a focus on upgrading weapons with
enchantments and special attacks so yeah
a huge step away from minecraft as we
know it the story will be a massive part
of this adventure as we see the story of
the arch imager the leader of those
people who repeatedly kill me in raids
we'll see how he claimed his throne and
how his thirst for power consumed him an
interesting take on minecraft but what
do you think and will it come out in
April at present minecraft dungeons
drops on ps4 PC Xbox and switch I hope
it does make April but if not we'll
cover it again in future months
and finally a quick shout-out to my
friend Pedro which makes its way to ps4
on April 2nd I know pretty much every
other platform in the world has this so
why is this newsworthy Adam while this
bullet time action gun-toting ballet has
extras on ps4 in the shape of 14:1 for
game modifiers to keep the game feeling
fresh and also there's community
improvements like an onscreen timer and
the hidden heads-up display option for
purists definitely my kind of game on
April 2nd
[Music]
so that's where we are in the month of
April 2020 did I miss any awesome games
comment below and I'll give you a heart
to get your recommendation noticed by
more people I'm Adam from PlayStation
granade I'm still stuck indoors I hope
you are too wash your hands let's try
and get through this together
been a pleasure I'll see you soon also
if you got this far in the video I
really do appreciate it if you tell me
what kind of things you'd like me to
cover over the next few months I have a
lot more time on my hands than I
expected to so if you've got this far
you should dictate what we do in future
I mean it I will play anything I will
even play minecraft if you think it's
worth it let's do something different
thanks very much for your time it's much
appreciated I'm Adam I've already said
that see you soon bye
[Music]